ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en mis redes sociales
yo comparto todo a través de mi música
es la creatividad el vínculo el puente
que tiro hacia los demás son sus
emociones es aquello que me mueve y de
alguna u otra manera es muy personal
pero al mismo tiempo cuando exploró yo
en las redes sociales pues es un ocio
muy limitado por lo tanto me topo con
literalmente posteos como este
este es un twitter
posteó un importante periódico de
nuestro país la jornada y la verdad es
que es un encabezado muy positivo es un
encabezado que me llenó de alegría
leerlo cuando entiendo que no solamente
están celebrando la nueva creación
musical que lancé sayón sino también los
años de trayectoria y de carrera y
entonces claro uno empieza a leer
emocionado todo este contexto y cuando
me topo con los comentarios y leo el
primero el primero dice pero pregúntale
si es feliz entonces digo claro eso es
para mí no o sea la pati peñaloza le
preguntan pregúntale para ti a él y si
es feliz y entonces yo de manera
automática entró en un proceso
de observación y de reflexión
me preguntó
pero
[Música]
qué tienen de peleado los conceptos de
felicidad con la tenacidad y la
elegancia automáticamente entro en un
proceso creativo esto es positivo para
mí por lo tanto voluntariamente salgo
volada de sentir lástima por mí misma
por este comentario absolutamente
irónico y entonces me refugio en un
lugar positivo en un lugar seguro para
mí la creatividad porque si nosotros
hablamos de creatividad estamos
de alguna u otra manera empezando a
desmembrar la idea la voz del otro esa
es como cuestión irónica que yo
realmente quiero llevarla a un lugar
positivo y pensar no estoy desmembrando
una idea
de otro y esto promueve que yo sienta
curiosidad y que yo sienta un impulso
por entender que quiso decir este chico
entonces
claro yo me siento
el cirujano médico que tú vas y visitas
porque tienes un dolor y entonces este
cirujano te observa
de diagnóstica
te médica o inclusive puede decirte 20
para acá te voy a sentar aquí o te voy a
acostar en esta plancha vamos a abrir
una parte de tu cuerpo vamos a
diseccionar la y vamos a desmembrar la y
vamos a ir a fondo a profundidad a
entender qué es lo que te está doliendo
y entonces vamos no inclusive a curarla
sino a proteger esa parte a pesar de tu
dolor
bueno yo me siento igual yo me siento
entonces como el músico cirujano que
tiene la oportunidad de desmembrar un
tejido social de desmembrar tu voz y
entender hacia dónde vas qué quieres
decir desde una empatía distinta no
desde un lugar oscuro de depresión donde
qué dolor porque dijeron esto de mí sino
lo contrario desde un lugar positivo un
lugar creativo un lugar seguro para mí
en donde de alguna u otra manera estoy
descendiendo o bueno
desmembrando esta idea
y me siento capaz de curar tu dolor un
dolor que seguramente es mío porque este
es un tejido social el que yo estoy ya
desbaratando es un tejido es la duda que
nos une a ti ya mí y entonces si el arte
cura y entonces lo único que puedo
pensar es quiero escribir una canción
que te permita sentir alivio porque
claro de alguna u otra manera todos
tenemos una voz una voz que elevar que
desarrollar una voz que queremos
compartir pero
estamos tiene muchísimas muchísimos
prismas y carismas y todos nos
pertenecen por lo tanto si me lo
permiten me encantaría desmembrar a mi
voz porque claro mi voz me ha dado
identidad no sólo como cantante me ha
dado identidad porque a través de mis
canciones he dicho lo que pienso he
dicho lo que siento y entonces podría
servirnos hoy de ejemplo para desmembrar
la voz
producido por la vibración de las
cuerdas vocales
cualidad timbre o intensidad de ese
sonido
músico que canta palabra o vocablo
autoridad o fuerza que reciben las cosas
por el dicho u opinión común opinión
fama rumor medio a través del cual se
expresan los sentimientos y opiniones de
una persona o colectividad
con suelo
[Música]
chang
y claro trabajar con mi voz
me ha permitido reconocer el propósito
de mi vida
y en este propósito he podido inclusive
sentirme feliz pero bueno ya quedamos
que la felicidad es un concepto ambiguo
es un concepto extraño entonces por
favor
no te sorprendas si sentirte feliz te
hace sentir miserable
pero no te confundas ni te asustes
porque en este camino la realidad es que
sentirse de alguna u otra manera feliz y
miserable lo único que te está indicando
es que crecer duele
y entonces tú estás aquí
y tu propósito está allá hay todo un
trayecto que recorrer eso quiere decir
absolutamente que en este trayecto y te
lo aseguro vas a tener complicaciones
adversidades muchos obstáculos que
vencer
y para eso va a requerir ser valiente
hay el y no jodas
que ser valiente es muy sencillo es
sentir miedo es estar en temor pero a
pesar de eso controlarlo y atravesar
este camino porque tú sabes tú lo tienes
muy claro que ese destino es tuyo te
pertenece sólo a ti nadie te lo va a
quitar y de alguna u otra manera tienes
el espacio y totalmente la certeza de
que puedes llegar a él así que lo más
importante en este trayecto
es saber que para ganar
hay que saber perder
y claro si hablamos de perder yo les
puedo explicar que lo primero que yo
pierdo es mi voz
porque claro todas las experiencias de
mi vida pasan a través del filtro de mi
voz entonces de alguna u otra manera he
tenido que defender no solamente mis
ideales mis canciones mi manera de
pensar la música extraña que escribí
porque no tiene nada que ver con lo
comercial del lead
y en esta defensa por la libertad
creativa
muerto de miedo
y va a decir otra palabra
así que en este temor profundo
desde muy niña me paso porque claro yo
desde muy niña era diferente por
supuesto el resto de mis compañeros de
la escuela no decían nada
empático
por no decir interesante para mí así que
claro un día yo estoy muy molesta en mi
casa tengo 10 años y pienso a mí
honestamente de nada me sirve sentir
esta injusticia en mi casa entonces me
visto de guerrera me pongo porque voy
para la batalla y voy con mi papá
alberto y le digo alberto tenemos que
hablar
y entonces mi papá super amoroso pero
claro el que necesita si se sienta y me
abracé y dime yo
absolutamente pierdo control
porque él es afable amoroso y yo iba de
guerrera no a decir aquí esto está muy
mal porque yo siento una injusticia
entonces
me tira la guardia
y cuando él me pregunta que tienes que
decirme yo 10 años
pierdo la voz
y en lugar de decir lo que claramente
tengo en mi mente
comienzo a sollozar
y sonidos guturales que no dicen
absolutamente nada por supuesto alberto
empieza a desesperarse pero qué pasa que
tienes y que tengo y qué pasa lo único
que pasa es que yo no siento justicia
aquí nadie me trata igual no hay equidad
ni en mi casa acá
entonces esto traduzcamos lo llevémoslo
a la vida profesional algunos años
después en mi adolescencia y ahora de
adulta y claro en discusiones con
managers
músicos productores con directores de
sellos disqueros con la prensa con
medios de comunicación pero qué ocurre
hablamos de un trayecto cierto yo ya
llevo un trayecto y mi voz mi voz cada
vez es más fuerte es más clara es más
categórica pero sobre todo está diciendo
y sabe perfectamente
el discurso que debe enunciar y yo voy
cada vez más fuerte más fuerte más
fuerte entregando ese discurso y casi
siempre me dijeron eres una intensa
me lo dijeron para mal
pero yo supe serlo para bien porque
saben qué
mi manera de vivir apasionada dice mucho
más que mil palabras
y a veces es que a veces yo siento que
callamos cosas importantes de nuestra
vida
pero al mismo tiempo decimos cosas que
no edifican que no tiran puentes ni
líneas con los demás o sea que la
cagamos no
lo que es importante es decir que la
libertad de una voz
exige y demanda
compromiso
integridad
honestidad
liderazgo
demanda responsabilidad
es que la voz es poder
es que tu voz tiene un poder y cuando tú
en este poder te administras realmente
tienes que estar consciente de que la
voz con poder tiene dominio autoridad y
autoridad
ahora sí qué
protesta
por lo tanto también tienes que estar
muy ubicado en que todo lo que digas
tiene la habilidad de influenciar a los
demás a uno o varios individuos y esto
esto es una gran gran responsabilidad
porque yo no hablo de ser un político
yo no hablo de ser políticamente
correctos eso realmente es un ejercicio
cosmético del discurso y yo no estoy
denunciando esto lo que te estoy
diciendo es que tu poder está en tu voz
o viceversa tu voz es poder y sabes que
a veces
el poder de una voz se ejerce desde el
silencio
es un concepto
algo ambiguo porque
siempre nos han dicho habla explica t
para veces callarse también tiene un
énfasis
en la música
los silencios son tan importantes como
los sonidos una pausa en la música es
una pieza indispensable para una
composición musical es drama
es un efecto que permite que el sonido
tenga figura y valor
por lo tanto
yo pienso claro el poder de mi voz
cuando hablo
y el poder de mi voz
cuando cayó
y esque
no estoy hablando
literalmente no estoy diciendo que mi
voz no tenga identidad cuando no hablo
lo que te estoy diciendo es que tu voz
tiene identidad
y yo no soy solamente el músico que
habla o que canta soy el músico que dice
soy la mujer que expresa soy la mujer
que saben callar o que aprende a callar
y soy la mujer que de alguna u otra
manera se hace fuerte en este trayecto
y busca la felicidad un concepto tan
ambiguo como miserable pero sabes qué
el poder de tu voz tiene que ver con
alzar la y alzar la voz estirar puentes
no elevar muros
así que tienes una herramienta natural
para poder establecer puentes con los
demás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]